be our guest be our guest hood off sell
this to the test
legendary theatrical lighting designers
Jules Fisher and Peggy Eisenhower we're
trying to figure out how would Lumiere
like this scene how's he going to make
it look like a show and they said you
know realistically you know we can have
butter dishes with candles in them and
they become footlights Klum it takes a
tray and she kind of takes the moonlight
it makes it shine so the light that
comes from the moon and from the fire
enters into the space and hips imaginary
objects objects that are not there when
we shoot and we imagine what is going to
be the result of light hitting an
imaginary object and reflecting the
information that they gave us in
previous showed us what those moments
should look like
we then embellished them to make him
look theatrically lit so as those CG
plates are twirling the lights in the
room are real they were created by these
lighting designers imagining how this cg
plate would give off like once we would
roll the back laid then we would go back
and place a you know fully photo-real
Lumiere and Cogsworth on the table and
rerun the lighting then we would see a
blue light ray across them and then the
animators could see exactly what that
means to look and feel like
[Applause]
[Music]
you shall see your fandom